we're back with stanley tucci the
brilliant actor who also knew his way
around a cocktail shaker
when did you start making cocktails
i started making them when i was in my
20s
and um and now i seem to be still making
them
well i actually wanted to introduce you
to someone who's
actually a bit of a connoisseur of
beverages as well
it's seven-year-old leo
kelly whose videos are under the
uh pen name the shirley temple king
and they too have exploded online take a
look
what's better than three cherries
what could be any better no one knows
but the taste might be better
let's give it a try this is ginger ale
wow it is very very good this is
actually one of our really good chili
temple i give it like an
8.8
and that's out of a 10. please welcome
leo kelly aka
the shirley temple king nice to meet you
hi leo how are you how are you
i'm so great you know i'm a big follower
of yours but i can't believe you're here
in person
this is crazy it's really crazy
will you teach mr tucci and myself
how to make a shirley temple well
actually it's not sure a temple i'd put
an
italian twist just for mr tucci
oh italian for mr
[Applause]
my god i want to go pray in that temple
i love it teach us well first of all you
gotta have some ice
personally i like fancy ice like cubed
ice or crushed ice
so we got crushed ice right here
then we got instead of the ginger wheel
some
san pedigrino italian sparkling water
oh this looks beautiful oh and it has a
gorgeous like
blush color yeah oh my gosh go ahead
wait is it good oh my gosh
i think i just discovered a new
drink to bring home to my daughter's leo
well we gotta finish it off okay let's
do it
so instead of instead of the grenadine
fun fact
did you know that some cherries are
actually made in
italy i didn't well now you know
no i do and now stanley knows too i mean
he probably
already knew but so
so we're going to be using cherry juice
and the cherries
okay pour in the cherry juice about how
much leo
just to make it like a red not too dark
not too pink
okay eyeball it eyeball it yeah all
right
leo yours looks so much better than mine
honestly i think yours looks better than
mine well mine's all melded together
yours is looking like a sunset
and then i already put in three cherries
three or more
that's my perfect number three three
three or more
it doesn't matter stanley it's a lucky
number
how many how many cherries do you like
to put in a drink
actually i've never put cherries in a
drink i usually put olives in a drink
and and i always put three
[Music]
oh leo you love a garnish yes i do i
do shall we group what is this we shall
we what garnish should we put on
um i think we should do some oranges
okay gotta get that vitamin c stanley
will you talk me through this what
garnish should i use
a blood orange a kiwi
a lime use a kiwi
yeah yeah i would use an egg maybe
obviously you didn't take my advice and
use the kids well
i i you know now i'm just feeling like
basically through me
again leo your drink just looks way
better than mine
leo wait i want to see leo's i can't see
leo's drinking
oh okay oh leo my gosh
it's so elegant i know
beautiful all right
stanley do you see mine it's pretty
nutsy no i think it's beautiful
cheers thank you so much
cheers thank you so much
stanley cheers to you
leo cheers to you well you know what
everybody a chef's kiss to stanley tucci
and royal dolls the witches available
now on hbo max
and to leo the shirley temple king who
is the king of social media
and now stanley is the king of social
media with his cocktails
this is perfect thank you guys cheers